foreign
when some people say anime is all about
creating memories I agree a lot of times
anime is all about the moments the Epic
fights the grand speeches the comedic
segments that left us in stitches the
tear-jerking farewells the speeches that
light a fire from within us or
encapsulated in Clips such is a
testament to how powerful a medium it is
then there are these moments likewise
memorable but for a completely different
reason these my friends are anime
moments that are downright bizarre is
that or something that caught me off
guard which made them so memorable for
me as such it's probably one of my
subjective videos by far but I hope that
you're going to enjoy the show these are
the strangest moments that really made
their Mark In My Memory remember when
food Wars pulled out a JoJo reference
food Wars is known for a lot of things
we got the cooking and great chapter
designs the notorious latter seasons and
the fan service especially so when
megumi stepped up against Rio in what
looked to be an insane Face-Off we all
expected the usual fan service you know
the presentation that could make you
regret watching this cooking show in
public especially when people not into
the community are involved but to get a
JoJo reference out of all things it's
like the show transcended the medium and
broke the fourth wall with it hopping
over to the whole JoJo reference
bandwagon the anime fans just love to
say online golden wind fans Feast your
eyes on this glorious scene seven page
murder brought to life in a completely
unrelated anime and still looking as
sick as ever to be fair those are some
amazing looking stand designs really
awesome and cool in an unironic way I'd
say
foreign
then we have this awkward as hell moment
from daily lives of high school boys
this is the most random scene I'll be
covering so far and I think it's quite
emblematic of what daily lives of high
school boys brings to the table the
whole show is just so Random it's so
crazy but everything seems to be done
with an uneasy level of restraint like
this guy he didn't Ori right here poor
guy tries his best to avoid reacting to
not embarrass yassan but I think it's
got the completely opposite effect right
it's a type of Comedy That You Don't See
often in modern anime but I think it
still has its share of fans everything
that can go wrong did go wrong in this
scene that lasts a little under a minute
I wasn't exactly sure how to react to it
though to be honest it's one of those
fourth War breaks that aren't as blatant
as the presentation looks completely
like a parody of those rom-com cliches
with the tripping the wind the bad drink
all of that when it's all said and done
yasan looks so clumsily cute
next we have the legendary toothbrush
scene from nisei monogatri
[Music]
we all know that monogatri as a Series
has no shortage of fan service sure it's
not as Brazen and in your face there's a
lot of the etchy titles out there but
this isn't a franchise you typically
show the more conservative side of the
fandom it still doesn't make it any less
of a show and for all it's worth it's a
very very good franchise with a lot of
meaningful themes before throwing scenes
with presentation like this out of
nowhere real wholesome and really a
scene is pretty much defined Nissan
monogatri at least in the meme side of
things ask random people why they think
of nisse monogatri and you'll likely get
a passing mention of this scene in some
way and that's how you know you made one
hell of an impression it's nowhere as
crazy as most of the entries the follow
and it's probably the second most
serious one in the bunch that should key
in on what you could expect
[Music]
what after that how about this scene
from plastic Nissan
Dash does it
oh look bullying scene in the alley
we've seen a lot of these in anime
before haven't we and this one's got the
hero saving the day standing against the
light it's one of the more common
cliches in anime and it is so because a
lot of times it works however if there's
one show that out does every take out of
this scene and the sheer absurdity of it
and it's this one from plastic Nissan
the answer of this funfield show is
already enough to clue anyone in on
what's about to happen this isn't a show
to take seriously and if you need proof
of that then just look at the way the
day gets saved just Insanity that you'll
find nowhere but in anime hipster are so
powerful bullies get sent packing and
eyes get seared for time Memorial truly
the Pinnacle of Animation I swear I
thought the video was lagging but it's
the frames not being able to keep up
with the power of the hip thrusts
for something way more serious however
we take a look at glypnier
I wasn't sure what to make of Glide
Panera first you know looking back it's
all sort of awesome but I'd almost
forgotten about how crazy the whole
thing was thanks to the baron season it
aired in I gave it a watch it started
out great with an air of mystery and it
showed promise of being a fun high
octane action series then came the time
shuichi and Claire had to fight together
and we suddenly got to see what
shuichi's real Powers were literally
opening himself up so Claire can walk in
plant herself in what looked like his
flesh interior before she Pilots him
kind of soaking fluids and all I know
people have made jokes about the titans
in Attack on Titan being flesh Mecca but
this just felt like a super literal
interpretation of it I never thought I'd
see the scenes are certainly not
something with meme value like the
previous entries it's far from it but
I'd be lying if I was to say I wasn't
taken aback with how the whole fighting
together thing was taken to such a
literal manner in glypner still the
feelings of speechless astonishment
didn't last as what follows was one of
the most awesome fights in the season
one that stabbed the show is one of my
must-watch titles at that time
and I'll close with the king of comedy
Gintama
um
[Music]
when people say that anime is relatable
you often think of the big moments a
failed confession a character who acts
and talks like that guy in your class
something that speaks to us in a
spiritual way mostly shows of grandeur
whether they be legit or to be in the
tear of their edgy classmate of yours
comparing himself to hachiman or Ayana
Goji with some copy pasted walls of text
filled with Emojis but have you expected
anime to be relatable in this way tell
me I'm not the only one who's found
myself in the predicament shared by
these guys from Gintama who would have
thought the running out of toilet paper
could be presented in such an
eye-poppingly serious yet hilarious way
owe it up to Gintama to come up with
this masterpiece then again running out
of toilet paper is always going to be
serious business and don't let anyone
tell you otherwise you'll know if you've
been in this predicament before remember
always take toilet paper with you
wherever you go just a live pro tip
courtesy of one of the best Shonen anime
ever created
and that's it for this video those are
some of the moments that have become
memorable to me for reasons you might
not have expected would you like to see
a volume 2 of this if this video gets 15
000 likes then I'll consider it once
again thank you for watching and I hope
you have a great day ahead see you next
time